بشكل لافت تعود كييف العاصمه الاوكرانيه
لتتصدر المشهد مع تعرضها لهجمه صاروخيه
تصفها السلطات الاوكرانيه بانها غير
مسبوقه في كثافتها وقوتها وتنوعها بصواريخ
روسيا قالت السلطات انها باليستيه ومجنحه
وفرط صوتيه الهجوم الذي يعتبر التاسع على
التوالي منذ بدايه شهر مايو جاري تم ب 30
صاروخا من نوع كروز وفق قائد القوات
الاوكرانيه اطلقت من منصات بحريه وجويه
وارضيه بينها صاروخ اسكندر في هجوم متزامن
من اتجاهات مختلفه تتحدث القوات
الاوكرانيه عن صد تسعه وعشرين منها
بالاضافه الى طائرتين مسيرتين من طرز شاهد
وطائره استطلاع تؤكد وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
ان قوتها استهدفت في اكثر من هجوم
مستودعات للذخيره الاجنبيه ودمرت مدافع
هاودسر واعترضت منظومه الصواريخ هايمرس
واستخدمت منظومه الصواريخ الجويه المضاده
للطائرات
تعزو المتحدثه باسم قياده عمليه الجنوب
الاوكرانيه الهجوم الروسيه الواسعه الى
مقاله انه محاوله لاستنفاذ الدفاعات
الجويه الاوكرانيه مع تزويد الدول الغربيه
كييف بانظمه دفاع جوي من هذه المنظومات
نظام اس 300 ويصل مداه الى 250 كيلومترا
وهو قادر على التصدي الصواريخيه التي لا
تتجاوز سرعتها
4500 متر في الثانيه اضافه الى منظومه
نيسانس الامريكيه بمدى يصل الى 50
كيلومترا وهو نظام متوسط المدى يمكنه
التعامل مع مقاتلات ومروحيات وصواريخ كروز
ومسيرات فمنظومه ايريستي الالمانيه بمدى
يصل لنحو 40 كيلومترا وهي من افضل انظمه
الدفاع متوسطه المدى وتستطيع صد الطائرات
المقاتله والمروحيات والصواريخ كروز
والمسيرات
تتبع هذه التطورات اعلان وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه قبل ايام استخدامها الصواريخ من
طراز كنجال في كييف تفوق سرعتها سرعه
الصوت لتدمير محطه رادار متعدده الوظائف
وخمس قذفات لمنظومه باتريوت الامريكيه
المضاده للطائرات لكن مسؤولين امريكيين
قللوا من الاضرار التي لحقت بالمنظومه
وقالوا انها لا تزال قيد التشغيل ولم
يتضرر مكون الرادار مؤكدين ان اصلاحه لا
يتطلب سحبه من ساحه المعركه ومنظومه
الامريكيه يصل مداها الى 160 كيلومترا
وتعتبر نظاما دفاعيا بعيد المدى قادرا على
حمايه المنشاه العسكريه والقواعد من
الهجمات الجويه ويشمل ردارا ومحطه تحكم
ومولد طاقه ومنصات اطلاق ومركبه دعم
[موسيقى]